hey dr. Berg here in this video we're
going to talk about cholesterol I want
to give you the facts about cholesterol
right now there's a huge push to put
everyone in cholesterol medication and
to drive down the cholesterol way way
way I think is too low a normal
cholesterol is 200 that's the top level
200 about twenty years ago it used to be
225 so they keep lowering it down to 150
they're trying to get it down to 100 and
even if it is normal people stay in the
medication because they think well just
as a preventive thing because they're
concerned about cholesterol clogging the
arteries but let's just take a look at
about what cholesterol really really is
cholesterol is a precursor it's a
building block to all the sex hormones
testosterone estrogen progesterone
cortisol so when you cut this thing out
or cut it down too far you basically
starve off your hormones you start
having problems with estrogen
progesterone testosterone and things
like that and that's why men that take
cholesterol-lowering medication they end
up with low tea well you need
cholesterol to build it up the other
thing that people don't realize is that
sugar and refined carbohydrates
especially breads pasta cereal crackers
viscous waffles pancakes all convert
into cholesterol yes
that's where it really comes from so
what we should be doing is adjusting
that not adjusting this cholesterol also
acts as a band-aid so it helps heal the
arteries the reason why it goes in the
arteries in the first place is there
some type of inflammation or something
that needs to be healed and cholesterol
comes in there and forms a little bit of
a band-aid but guess what causes the
inflammation high insulin from the sugar
people eat other fact is that 90 percent
of the cholesterol is recycled so if
cholesterol was so bad why does our body
recycle it it's good it gets recycled
through the gallbladder and the liver
and even the intestines so in the
gallbladder you have something called
bile that helps to break down
cholesterol people that don't have a
goal
or have a liver problem or don't have
enough bio their cholesterol will tend
to build up and they can get a fatty
liver so what do we do trying to lower
the cholesterol why not just give the
person some bile salts to help break
down - to balance this cholesterol they
don't do that all the cells on your body
need cholesterol the AI needs
cholesterol the red nut needs
cholesterol these are some facts that
you need to know to explain your doctor
and to know yourself before you start
jumping on the medication because
there's things that you can do naturally
I would start with eliminating the sugar
and maybe even supporting the liver or
getting some bile salts and then if it
comes back to normal then why take the
medication because there's a lot of side
effects so I just want to briefly cover
the facts about cholesterol hope that
helped and I'll see you in the next
video